Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Dans quelques jours, sort Napoléon,
le dernier film de Ridley Scott.
Du coup, avec Thibault de la chaîne
Histoire appliquée, on a décidé de faire
une petite battle autour d'anecdotes
portant sur la vie de l'Empereur.
J'ai un peu fouillé
et j'ai appris des choses très étonnantes.
Le gagnant ne repartira pas
les mains vides.
Le perdant lui offre une place
pour aller voir le film.
Et accroche-toi, Jamy,
Napoléon n'a
presque aucun secret pour moi !
C'est ce qu'on verra !
Première question, Thibault :
tu sais évidemment
que le tombeau de Napoléon
se trouve aux Invalides, à Paris.
Mais as-tu déjà entendu parler
de cette rumeur selon laquelle
ce n'est pas la dépouille de Napoléon
qui se trouverait à l'intérieur ?
J'espère que tu plaisantes, Jamy !
Bien sûr que je la connais ton histoire !
Je connais même le nom de l'homme
qui a lancé la rumeur,
en tout cas, il l'a popularisée.
C'est Georges Rétif de la Bretonne, un
journaliste français passionné d'histoire.
En 1969,
il écrit un livre intitulé "Anglais,
rendez-nous Napoléon", dans lequel il affirme
que c'est le corps d'un autre homme
qui se trouverait aux Invalides.
- Bravo Thibault !
Ce livre a fait l'effet
d'une bombe au moment de sa sortie.
L'auteur affirme que peu de temps après
la mort de Napoléon, survenue le 5 mai 1821,
les Anglais auraient exhumé
son corps de sa tombe
et l'aurait remplacé
par les restes de son maître d'hôtel,
Cipriani, décédé
lui aussi à Sainte-Hélène,
mais trois ans plus tôt.
C'est donc la dépouille de Cipriani,
et non celle de Napoléon,
qui aurait été rapatriée à Paris
le 15 décembre 1840.
Exactement.
Et pour justifier sa thèse,
Rétif de la Bretonne
s'appuie sur différents éléments
mentionnés sur le rapport d'exhumation.
Les dents du mort sont très blanches,
alors que celles de Napoléon avaient
la réputation d'être très mauvaises.
Et puis, il y a aussi
ces deux vases qui contiennent le cœur
et l'estomac de l'Empereur.
Ils sont censés avoir été déposés
au coin du cercueil.
Or, bizarrement, on les retrouve
entre les jambes de la dépouille.
Est-ce que tu sais pourquoi les Anglais
auraient orchestré cette machination ?
Non, mais vas-y, je t'écoute.
À l'époque, ils craignaient que les Français
ne procèdent à des analyses toxicologiques
dans le but
de prouver que Napoléon a été empoisonné.
Pour éviter le scandale,
ils auraient donc transféré
les véritables cendres de l'Empereur
dans un endroit plutôt incongru.
- Tu sais où ?
- À l'abbaye de Westminster.
Napoléon
aurait été enterré sous une dalle anonyme.
Cette histoire a fait beaucoup de bruit
en 1969, au moment de la sortie du livre.
Puis on l'a oubliée, jusqu'en 2002,
où, pour être fixé
une bonne fois pour toutes,
un historien nommé Bruno Roy-Henry
propose que l'on fasse un prélèvement
ADN sur la dépouille qui se trouve
dans le cercueil des Invalides.
Afin de le comparer avec l'ADN
des descendants de la famille Bonaparte.
C'est ça ! La demande est faite
auprès de l'État français.
La réponse du ministère
de la Défense tombe.
Elle est sans appel : c'est niet.
D'ailleurs, sachez qu'aucun historien digne de ce nom
ne valide cette hypothèse farfelue.
Le corps de Napoléon a été authentifié
devant plusieurs témoins dignes de foi
juste avant son transfert en France.
Donc, jusqu'à preuve du contraire,
absolument rien ne permet de dire
que ce n'est pas son corps
qui se trouve aux Invalides.
Tiens Jamy,
une question que tout le monde se pose :
est-ce que tu sais pourquoi,
sur de nombreuses représentations de l'époque,
Napoléon a la main sur l'estomac ?
On lit souvent
qu'il adoptait cette posture
en raison de douleurs
qu'il aurait eues à l'estomac.
Eh bien, pas du tout !
En fait, il s'agit tout simplement
d'une façon de se tenir en respectant
les bonnes manières.
Dans la haute société de l'époque,
il était très mal vu de se tenir
les bras ballants
ou même les bras croisés.
Et bien sûr, pas question
de mettre les mains dans les poches.
Il doit tenir son rang.
C'est un militaire.
Il monte à cheval.
Et lui, le petit Corse d'origine modeste,
il doit pouvoir montrer
qu'il est aussi bien élevé
que tous les grands d'Europe
qui attendent la moindre occasion
pour se moquer de lui.
D'ailleurs, Napoléon n'est pas le seul
à se tenir ainsi la main dans le gilet.
On retrouve cette posture
sur de nombreux tableaux
représentant des hommes importants
au début du XIXᵉ siècle.
Finalement, il ne faisait que suivre
la mode de son temps.
On continue avec les idées
reçues sur Napoléon.
On a beaucoup parlé de sa taille,
mais à ton avis, Thibault,
combien mesurait-il ?
De mémoire, ce n'est pas très grand,
quelque chose comme 1m65
il me semble.
- Perdu !
D'après son médecin, François Antommarchi,
il mesurait cinq pieds
cinq pouces, ce qui correspond à
un peu moins d'1m68.
Franchement, il abuse !
À trois centimètres près...
Je suis désolé, je n'étais pas loin.
Dans tous les cas,
Napoléon n'était pas très grand.
Les chiffres sont les chiffres !
- Tu mesures combien, Thibault ?
- Euh, 1m89
Évidemment, c'est grand.
Et d'une manière générale, aujourd'hui,
on estime qu'1m68, pour un homme,
c'est plutôt petit. Dans une manifestation
ou dans une rame de métro,
on aurait du mal à repérer Napoléon.
Mais si l'on compare à la taille moyenne
des hommes au début du XIXᵉ siècle,
qui était d'environ
1m64, on peut dire qu'il
était plutôt grand pour l'époque.
Mais alors, d'où lui vient
cette réputation ?
Eh bien, des Anglais !
Les peintres et les caricaturistes
le représentaient exagérément petit.
Une façon de se moquer de lui.
Tu marques un point Jamy, mais en fait,
ce n'est pas la seule explication.
Napoléon s'entourait d'hommes de très grande taille
pour composer sa garde d'élite.
Ils étaient affublés
de grands couvre-chefs et de plumets
qui les rendaient encore plus grands.
Alors, forcément, à leurs côtés,
il apparaissait plus petit
que dans la réalité.
Et puis, à cela, il faut ajouter qu'il
traîne comme un boulet
ce surnom de "petit caporal"
que lui avaient donné ses soldats
après la victoire de Lodi
contre les Autrichiens en 1796.
Ce grade totalement fictif
tendait surtout à souligner son courage
et non sa taille.
Mais ça a créé beaucoup de
confusion dans les esprits.
Tu l'as dit Jamy,
Napoléon
a souvent été l'objet de moqueries.
Par exemple, savais-tu qu'en 1779,
lorsqu'il intègre le collège d'Autun
en Saône-et-Loire, on se moque de lui
tant son accent corse est prononcé.
Et je peux même te dire que ses
camarades de classe le surnommaient
"la paille au nez" en référence à son prénom
que Napoléon lui-même prononçait
"Napollioné".
À cette époque,
il maîtrise si mal le français qu'il
doit suivre des cours pour s'améliorer.
Ça peut surprendre, mais ça s'explique.
Lorsque Napoléon arrive au monde,
le 15 août 1769,
la Corse n'est française que depuis un an.
On y parle deux langues proches
de l'italien : le corse et le génois.
C'est donc en langue corse
qu'il prononce ses premiers mots
et qu'il communique avec les membres
de sa famille pendant toute son enfance.
D'ailleurs, Napoléon
conservera toute sa vie son accent.
Il en gardera aussi
de nombreuses lacunes en orthographe
et pour éviter de faire trop de fautes
dans ses courriers,
on sait qu'il
les dictait à des secrétaires particuliers
qui, eux, étaient bons en grammaire
et en orthographe.
Mais cela ne l'empêchera pas de laisser
derrière lui un héritage considérable.
Je pense que vous allez être surpris
par les nombreuses institutions
qu'il a fondées et qui sont aujourd'hui
encore en place.
Est-ce que ça te dit
quelque chose, Thibault ?
Et là-dessus, il ne m'aura pas non plus !
Commençons par parler du bac, par exemple.
C'est une invention de Napoléon
qui l'a créé en 1808.
Pour préparer le bac, bien sûr,
il faut aller au lycée et ça, c'est
lui aussi : créé par la loi du 1ᵉʳ mai 1802.
D'ailleurs,
vous voyez cette personne en uniforme ?
Il s'agit d'un préfet.
Il est chargé de l'administration
dans les départements.
Sans Bonaparte, cet homme exercerait
sans doute une autre fonction.
C'est en effet lui qui a créé
le corps préfectoral le 17 février 1800.
Enfin, bon, Thibault a
quand même oublié le plus important :
ce livre,
le Code civil publié le 21 mars 1804.
Il regroupe l'ensemble
des lois qui régissent nos droits
et nos obligations : le mariage, le divorce,
la propriété ou encore l'héritage.
Bien sûr, il a évolué avec le temps,
mais près de la moitié
de ses 2280 articles
datent de l'époque napoléonienne.
Enfin, peut-être plus surprenant
encore, Napoléon
a aussi créé la Banque de France,
la Légion d'honneur,
le ramassage des ordures
et la numérotation des rues,
instaurée pour faciliter la collecte de l'impôt
destiné à financer ses guerres.
Et les platanes, il a oublié les platanes !
Tous ces arbres sur le bord de nos routes,
c'est Napoléon qui les a fait planter.
Et vous savez pourquoi ?
Pour que ses armées puissent marcher à l'ombre.
Puisque tu as l'air de tout connaître
sur Napoléon,
saurais-tu me dire combien il a eu
d'enfants ?
Enfin Jamy ! Évidemment que je le sais !
Il a eu un fils.
Napoléon François
Joseph Charles Bonaparte,
plus connu sous le nom de Napoléon II.
On l'appelait aussi L'Aiglon.
Il a été titré roi de Rome
à sa naissance en 1811,
mais il n'a régné que quinze jours.
Le pauvre garçon est mort prématurément
de la tuberculose
à l'âge de 21 ans, en 1832.
Il en a oublié quatre.
Napoléon a eu cinq enfants :
un fils légitime
dont Thibault vient de nous parler
et quatre autres enfants illégitimes, ceux-là.
Cette fois, c'est moi qui marque un...
Non, quatre points !
Ah, mais je le savais ça en plus !
Son premier fils se nommait Charles Léon.
Il est né en 1806 de ses amours
avec Éléonore Denuelle
de La Plaigne,
une suivante de sa sœur Caroline.
Plus porté au plaisir qu'au travail,
ce monsieur meurt en 1880 sans argent
et, dit-on, avec de lourdes dettes de jeu.
La même année, l'Empereur a eu
une aventure avec une certaine Françoise
Marie Émilie Leroy
qui donne naissance à une fille,
Émilie Pellapra, qui deviendra princesse de Brigode par le mariage.
Enfin, en 1810, Napoléon
aura deux autres fils :
Eugen Megerle de Mühlfeld, né de sa relation
avec une aristocrate autrichienne
dont je passe le nom de famille.
Comme son papa, Eugen Megerle
deviendra homme politique,
mais en Autriche.
Enfin, Alexandre, comte de Walewski,
fils de Marie Walewska,
une aristocrate polonaise.
Ce dernier a fait une brillante carrière
de sénateur et de ministre
en France, sous le règne de son cousin
Napoléon III.
Regardez bien, il y a un petit air
de famille, vous ne trouvez pas ?
Pour finir en beauté, Jamy,
petite devinette : est-ce que tu as déjà entendu
parler de Charles Joseph Bonaparte ?
Je parie qu'il ne sait pas.
Dans mon souvenir,
c'est un neveu de Napoléon,
mais un neveu américain.
- Je me trompe ?
- C'est presque ça.
Il s'agit plus exactement
de son petit neveu.
Il est né à Baltimore
d'une mère américaine
et a fait une brillante carrière politique
au sein du Parti républicain.
En 1905, il est même nommé
procureur général des États-Unis.
C'est l'équivalent de ministre
de la Justice en France.
Mais ce n'est pas le plus important.
Charles Joseph Bonaparte
est aussi à l'origine
d'un organisme que tout le monde connaît.
- Tu vois de quoi je parle, Jamy ?
- Tu ne m'auras pas, Thibault !
C'est lui qui a eu l'idée de créer aux États-Unis
le Bureau of Investigation, le B.O.I,
un organisme chargé de lutter
contre le crime organisé.
L'ancêtre,
on a deviné, du FBI.
Évidemment, je m'incline.
Je suis très mauvais en calculs,
mais je pense que c'est quand même toi
qui as gagné.
Du coup,
c'est moi qui t'invite
la semaine prochaine à découvrir
le nouveau film de Ridley Scott.
Merci pour cette battle en tout cas.
Quant à vous, je vous remercie
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo jusqu'au bout.
J'espère qu'elle vous a donné envie
d'en apprendre encore plus sur Napoléon.
Et puis, si ce format vous a plu,
n'hésitez pas à laisser un message
pour nous le dire. À très bientôt,
passez une excellente semaine
chers Épicurieuses et Épicurieux.